Buenas tardes Richi es una se ha
convertido esta tarde en el uno de los
primeros ministros más jóvenes de la
historia de este país con 42 años y el
primer Primer Ministro de origen indio
que recibe un país en caos marcado por
la inflación disparada con el aumento de
las facturas de la energía y del gas y
con una crisis política de la que su
partido el conservador ha sido
protagonista estamos a la espera de que
Richi es una hable públicamente y
presente Cuáles son esas primeras
acciones que tomará como Primer Ministro
para atender las necesidades del país
que tienen que ver con la crisis en la
economía y se sabe además que el Rey
Carlos III viajará de regreso a Londres
para esta noche y mañana muy
probablemente recibirá a listras en el
Palacio de buckingham para aceptar su
renuncia como la primera ministra más
breve en la historia de este país y para
pedir
entonces que en su nombre forme un nuevo
gobierno Y entonces iniciará el tercer
gobierno conservador de este año Luisa
Cuál es el apoyo real de sunan en el
país y además cuál se espera sea su
bandera de gobierno imagino que la
economía
sin duda la gente está clamando que se
tomen acciones que sean necesarias para
poder aliviar esa necesidad que tiene
todo el mundo por ejemplo de pagar las
rentas de poner alimentos en las mesas y
todo marcado por una creciente
inestabilidad financiera a nivel global
pero también impulsada por el aumento de
los precios de la energía y del gas
ahora sobre todo que se está acercando
el invierno y están bajando las
temperaturas la aceptación en el país de
Richi y sunat es altamente divisiva como
lo es en su partido es altamente
impopular porque subió los impuestos en
abril pero lo que espera la población es
que finalmente el partido conservador se
concentre en gobernar en atender esas
primeras acciones esas necesidades que
tiene la población y deje a un lado toda
la crisis y el dramatismo que ha
enfrentado el partido conservador una
reacción bien importante es que en la
primera la ministra principal de Escocia
ha celebrado la elección de Richi es una
como Primer Ministro Y eso nos habla de
que esas rencillas políticas entre
Londres y edimburgo podrían ser limadas
a dicho Nicolás que
se convierte en el Primer Ministro
británico asiático y es un momento
significativo sin embargo edimburgo
insiste en la importancia de que pueda
realizar muy probablemente en el 2023 un
nuevo referendo para independizarse del
Reino Unido Así que Richie sunat se
espera de más tarde unos primeros
apuntes de cuáles eran esas primeras
acciones que adoptará como Primer
Ministro